[موسيقى]
حصيله القتلى والمصابين ترتفع بين لحظه
واخرى والامال تتبدد بالعثور على ناجين
فهو اليوم السادس لوقوع الزلزال حيث تقل
الفرص بينما يزيد نفض الركام حجم الماساه
ماساه خلفت الاف المشردين والمنكوبين
واطفال مجهولون بالهويات او اسمنت ودمار
هائل ورغما حجم الدمار خرجت من بين الركام
بارقه امل بالعثور على نجينا امضوا اكثر
من 100 ساعه تحت الانقاض الطفله عائشه
كانت هي بارقه الامل وكبنا على مدى نحو
اربع ساعات متواصله عمليه انقاذها بعد
انقاذ شقيقتها الشقيقات الثلاث بقينا تحت
الانقاض سته ايام متواصله لكن كتب لهن
النجاه خرجنا من فم الموت رغم الزلزال
والبرد والظلام وضيق الركام بارقه دفعت
فرق الانق للوقوف صامدين على ناصيه
المباني المهدمه يواصلون البحث بلا ياس
ومصممون على الاستمرار ونحن نستمر معكم
مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه للزلزال المدمر
والعنيف الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
خرجت بعد ثلاث ساعات من محاولات الانقاذ
خرجت وهي بصحه
اذا افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال المدمر ارتفعت لتصل
الى اكثر من خمسه الاف قتيل كما افاد
المرصد ان حصيله الضحايا مؤهله للارتفاع
الى اكثر من سبعه الاف ضحيه في سوريا وذلك
لوجود مئات الجثث تحت الانقاض بعد
باعداد المفقودين وذكر المرصد كذلك ان فرق
الانقاذ تواجه صعوبه في الوصول لبعض
المناطق وذلك لتواجدها ضمن مناطق نفوذ
النظام السوري
قدم برنامج الغذاء العالم التابع للعالمي
التابع للامم المتحده مساعدات غذائيه
طارئه لمئه وخمسه عشر الف شخص في تركيا
وسوريا عقب وقوع زلزال المدمر في البلدين
الاثنين الماضي الامم المتحده اعلنت ايضا
عن توسيع نطاق مساعداتها الانسانيه
والاغاثيه لتشمل نحو 900 الف شخص من متضرر
الزلزال
حضرت مفوضيه الامم المتحده للاجئين من ان
الزلزال المدمر قد يكون شرد اكثر من خمسه
ملايين شخص في سوريا التي تعاني اساسا من
نزاع دام منذ نحو 12 عاما ممثل المفوضيه
في سوريا سيفانكا دانابالا اوضح ان
المفوضيه تركز على توفير الملجا والاغاثه
كالخيام والاغذيه البلاستيكيه والبطانيه
الحراريه وسجاد للنوم والملابس الشتويه
للمحتاجين
يا الزلزال يعيد فتح ملف كاد ينسى
خمسه فاصله ثلاثه مليون شخص على حافه
التشرد بفعل الزلزال
تقديرات اوليه اعلنتها مفوضيه الامم
المتحده للاجئين هذا رقم ضخم لدى شعب
يعاني اساسا من نزوح جماعي تقول ممثله
المفوضيه في سوريا قبل زلزال هناك نحو سته
فاصله ثمانيه مليون نازح داخل سوريا بسبب
الحرب منذ عام 2011
معاناه ليست جديده لكن ساقم الزلزال من
حدتها
[موسيقى]
اوضحت اداره الطوارئ والكوارث في تركيا ان
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب شرقي البلاد
الاثنين الماضي يماثل انفجار خمسمائه
قنبله ذريه في تاثيراتها المدمره واعلنت
السلطات التركيه في وقت سابق اليوم ارتفاع
اعداد قتل الزلزال الى خمسه وعشرين الف
وتزايد اعداد المصابين الى 80 الف
بالاضافه الى الالاف من المفقودين حتى
الان
وصف مارتن جريفيتس مسؤول المساعدات في
الامم المتحده الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
سوريا والتركيه باسوء حدث تشهده هذه
المنطقه في مئه عام وكشف المسؤول الاممي
عن وجود خطه من ثلاثه اشهر سيتم اتخاذها
لاغاده المناطق المنكوبه في كل من سوريا
وتركيا كما اعرب عن امله في ان تصل
المساعدات في سوريا الى المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره النظام والمعارضه على حد سواء لكنه
قال ان الامر لم يتضح بعد
جمعت الحمله الشعبيه السعوديه لغاده
المتضررين بالزلزال في سوريا وتركيا اكثر
من 251 مليون ريال وانطلقت الحمله قبل
ايام عبر منصه ساهم بعد توجيه العاهل
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وكان مركز
الملك سلمان للغاتاه والاعمال الانسانيه
اكد ان المساعدات السعوديه ستصل للمحتاجين
حيثما كانوا
ومعنا عبر الهاتف المتحدث الرسمي لمركز
الملك سلمان لاليغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
الدكتور سامر الجليطي او الجليلي عفوا
دكتور سامر مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
في هذه الساعه حتى هذه اللحظه كم طائره
وصلت الى يعني المناطق المنكوبه والمناطق
التي تضررت ايضا بالزلزال وما الذي تحمله
ايضا
حياكم الله استاذ نايف احييكم واحيي
انا هنا انا الان اقف عند المعبر معبر
حدودي بين تركيا
وسوريا انا كل من الشاحنات التي تعمل تحمل
مساعدات للداخل السوري هذه هي الحقيقه هي
مشاهدات التي تم اصرائها من الطائره التي
حطت في غاز عند هذه وامس ان تتحرك الى
الداخل السوري هذا اولا بالنسبه لسؤالكم
استاذ نايف
الحمد لله عز وجل في الطائرات حطت في مطار
غازي عنتاب
سحب المؤن ومساعدات انسانيه تركز على
المساعدات الطبيه وكذلك المشاهدات
الروائيه والمساعدات الغذائيه بالاضافه
كذلك هناك
طائرتان حملت حملت الفرق فرق الفريق
السعودي للبحث والانقاذ وكذلك المعدات
الثقيله الحقيقه المتقدمه التي يحملها
للمشاركه ودعم عمليات النصابها وهو يعني
الجزيره هنا انه الان يعمل في عدد من
المواقع سته مواقع يحاول فيها انشاء
الالقاب هنا فيها
ويقدم المساعدات المساعده الحقيقه في
محاوله انتشار الاحياء من تحت الالقاب في
نفس الوقت الموازي هناك الفرق التي حطت
فيها
الهلال السعودي وكذلك
متطوعين من الاطباء والممرضين
المركز الملك سلمان هم يتوزعون الان على
مراكز الايواء والخيام الحقيقه ويقدمون
الدعم في مجال الايواء
وبناء صيام وتقديم المساعدات الايوائيه
وكذلك يقدمون المشاهدات في مجال الطبي
والمشاهدات الطبيه من ناحيه المستخدم
الخدمات
المساعده في دعم مراكز الطبيه
المواقف التي اقامتها الصدفات التركيه كم
من المتوقع ان تصل طائره مساعدات من
المركز دكتور الى غازي عنتاب
المرحله الاولى العادله تم تسير ست طائرات
المجال مفتوح الان بعد توقيم هناك طريقه
الان على الارض يقيم الاحتياجات عن قرب
كذلك هناك فريق اخر يعمل على عمليه
الموارد من الداخل التركي وشراء
المستلزمات الاساسيه حسب الاحتياجات التي
يقراها يقررها الفريق اذا
في البدايه بدايه هذا الخير وبدايه هذا
العطاء
وسوف يستمر حسب توجيه سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الامين سوف يستمر بالحصيره هذا
العطاء ويستمر حتى وكذلك
يستمر مساعدات حتى باذن الله عز وجل يكون
هناك الحقيقه تغطيه او
ارتفاع او شبه اكتفاء في المناطق المحتاجه
بين ستوزع هذه المساعدات دكتور سامر هل
ستقتصر فقط على المناطق المتاثره بالزلزال
في تركيا ام ان هناك مساعدات تدخل الى
الشمال الغربي السوري وهذه المناطق ايضا
التي تضررت كذلك بالزلازل بشكل كبير طبعا
كما ذكرت لك انا الان اخذ على على هذا
المعبر وعبر على الازعاج هل هي الان قافله
من الشاحنات تتجه الى داخل السوري سوف
توزع في 20 نقطه في المناطق المتاثره في
داخل السوري هذه هي البدايه الحقيقه وسوف
يستمر باذن الله عز وجل تدفق هذه
المساعدات الى الداخل للسوري الى المناطق
المنصوبه وتوزيعها من خلال
الشركائنا شركائنا الذين عملوا معنا منذ
سنوات منذ بدايه الازمه السوريه حتى الان
وكذلك هناك
فريق الحقيقه يقيم الفريق من الشركه يقوم
على الرقابه والتقييم في توزيع هذه
المساعدات ممتاز يعني انتم تنسقون مع جهات
داخل سوريا ليقوموا بتوزيع هذه المساعدات
يعني دكتور وليس المركز وما سيقوم
بتوزيعها داخل الاراضي السوريه هكذا فهمته
كما تعلم استاذه نايف ان الوضع عند عمي في
داخل السوري الحقيقه ليست بالوضع الامن
يتم تنسيق مع السلطات السياسيه اولا هنا
في تركيا ثم يتم التنسيق مع المنظمات
الانسانيه
السوري وهي الحقيقه
اذا صح التعبير فهي عمليات معقده جدا في
التنسيق
وبدات منذ اطلاق منذ انصرف او
التنبيه
نعم نحن لا ندخل الشمال السوري بسبب الوضع
لكننا نعمل من خلال المنظمات موثوقه عملت
معنى لسنوات في مجال الاضافه وغيرها حبوب
مجال الطبي وكذلك مجال الايواء اشكرك جزيل
الشكر عبر الهاتف المتحدث الرسمي لمركز
الملك سلمان لغاثه والعمال الانسانيه
الدكتور سامر الجطيلي
وصلت الى مطار غازي عنتاب في تركيا صباح
اليوم الطائره الاغاثيه السعوديه السادسه
والتي تحمل على متنها 98 طنا من المساعدات
الاغاثيه تشتمل على المواد الغذائيه
والخيام والبطانيات والحقائب الايوائيه
بالاضافه الى المواد الطبيه ياتي ذلك ضمن
الجسر الاغاثي السعودي الذي يسيره مركز
الملك سلمان للغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
لمساعده متضرر الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا
يواصل فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي مهمات
التدخل والاسناد في حالات الكوارث داخل
وخارج السعوديه ولدعم الدول ايضا اخر تلك
الدول هي تركيا بعد وقوع الزلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
اعلنت منظمه الدفاع المدنيه السوريه القود
البيضاء انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال شمال غرب سوريا
والبدء بعمليات انتشال الجثث بعدما اصبحت
فرص العثور على ناجين شبه منعدمه
منها طاي جنوب تركيا ينضم الينا مفرد
العربيه عمار الهندي عمار مرحبا بك معي في
هذه النشر عمر ربما انت كنت ايضا تتابع
صوره اخرى مختلفه لديك فيها طي عن محاولات
الانقاذ انتشال ايضا ناجين من المنطقه
التي تتواجد بها في الطائف في المقلب
الاخر كانت الزميل غسان ابو اللوز ايضا
لديه صوره مختلفه كيف هي الصحيحه من حولك
الى اين وصلت عمليات الانقاذ والبحث
والتقصي عن ناجين
هنالك خطوط عريضه مهمه في عمليه البحث عن
الناجين الان في هاتاي استجدت اولا هم
يستخدمون يعني اجهزه حديثه هنالك فرق
صينيه هنالك فرق من كوريا الجنوبيه ولديهم
اجهزه متطوره هذه الاجهزه تستطيع نايف ان
ترصد الحركه والانفاس وحراره الجسد وبعض
الاجهزه والكاميرات يعني اذا كان هنالك
امكان لدخولها تدخل لتشاهد ما الذي يحدث
داخل الانقاذ ولكن يعني كنت في حديث منذ
قليل مع احد رجال الانقاذ من فرقه استونيه
تتواجد هنا حيث نقف لان هنالك بلاغ بان
هنالك شخص على قيد الحياه وصدرت منه اصوات
سالت اكثر عن كيفيه العمل وكيف لماذا
احيانا يكون هنالك صوت وبعد بعدها يعني
يعني يعلن بانه ليس هنالك ناجين وليس
هنالك صوت وساجوب الكاميرا وانا اتحدث
لاوريكا المشهد هنا في هذا الحي المدمر
وسط انطاكيا في هاتاي اخبرني بانهم ينتظ
صوتا يجب ان يكون هنالك صوت للتاكد بان
الشخص على قيد الحياه ايضا استمعت لي يعني
لشهادات اخرى من شبان سوريين بانهم سمعوا
اصواتا لاشخاص تحت الانقاض وحينما جاءت
فرق الانقاذ لتفحص الموقع اخبروهم بانه
ليس هنالك اصوات هنالك في هذا الحاله
احتمالات احتمال الاول ان يكون يهيئ للشخص
من شده الامل بان هنالك صوت وتاتي الفرقه
وتقول له مثلا للاسف لم نرصد الاصوات
باستخدام الاجهزه ولم نرصد ايه حركات او
وجود احياء وهنالك احتمال اخر ان شيئا ما
يحدث ويعيق عمل هذه الاجهزه للوصول فعلا
الى اشخاص استطاعوا ان يتحدثوا مثلا مره
ولم يتمكنوا من التحدث مره اخرى هنالك
حاله انا وقفت عليها اليوم وكانت شديده
الغرابه
فتاه عمرها 28 عام كانت تحت الانقاض كانوا
رجال الانقاض يبحثون يعني يزيلون الدمار
وفجاه سمعوا لها وحينما حاولوا التواصل
معها سالوها ما اذا كانت تستطيع نايف ان
تصدر رده فعل معينه بدقات معينه تدق ثلاث
مرات على سبيل المثال ان كانت حيه وفعلا
الفتاه فعلت ذلك واستجابت لمطالبهم
واسئلتهم ودقت ثلاث مرات وبعدها جاؤوا
بشخص من اسرتها او قريب لها وطلبوا منه
رقم هاتفها جرب احد رجال الامن الاتصال
بها وانا تحدثت مع شخصيا اتصل بها اجابت
الفتاه على الهاتف لمده 19 ثانيه وبعد ذلك
انقطع الاتصال بالهاتف اصبح يعني ليس فيه
بطاريه للاتصال به وبعدها بعد ذلك جاء
فريق من كوريا الجنوبيه وفحص المكان اكد
انها على قيد الحياه بعدها بساعه استمر
عمل فريق صيني باجهزه متطوره يعني يرصد
الحركه والانفاس والحراره اكد انه لا حياه
ولا وجود لاشخاص على قيد الحياه في ذلك
المكان وهذا الذي كان غريب جدا في هذه
الحاله التي كنا رصدناها على الهواء
مباشره ولكن هذا الامر اليوم نحن في اليوم
السادس طبعا هنالك من يعني اشخاص متشائمين
واشخاص يعني يفترضوا ان الامل انقطع لا
وجود لهذا الانقطاع للامل لانه اليوم في
خروج هذه الطفله يعني مبشر ودليل كافن على
انه يمكن فعلا ان يعيش الشخص ايام على قيد
الحياه وكنا طبعا يعني رصدنا اكثر من موقع
يناير في هذه المساله لانه هلا الان
الصراع الصراع الوصول الى الاحياء صراع
الوصول الى اشخاص لا يزال في اليوم السادس
وطبعا يعني الظروف صعبه الوقت نعم نعم بكل
تاكيد صح تعبيرك صحيح هو صراع الوقت
والحرب مع الوقت للوصول اليهم الدمار هائل
هذا الحي مثلا يعني حي في داخل احياء
انطاكيا نحن دخلنا الى وسطها الى داخل
الاحياء السكنيه هي مدمره بالكامل هنالك
طبعا تحذيرات كان الجيش متواجد قبل قليل
ومنعنا من دخول طريق في هذا الاتجاه لانه
اكد ان هنالك بنايه على وشك ان تنهار وانت
كما تعلم سجل اليوم انهيار لبنايه في
انطاكيا في نعم في هاتاي وعلى رجال
الانقاذ وهم يعملون لانه احد احدى
المشكلات الكبيره نايف انه يكون مثلا
هنالك عائله محتجزه في تسويه في بنايه لم
تنهار بشكل كامل فياتي رجال الانقاذ للعمل
داخل هذه التسويه بخطا ما او بحركه ما
تنهى غير متوقعه تنهار البنايه على رؤوس
العاملين وهذا الامر فيه خطر كبير جدا
ومشكله كبيره هذه البنايات المهدمه بشكل
جزئي والمهدده بالانهيار هي بالالاف
وبالتالي نعم اسمعك نايف يعني انا كنت
صراحه اود السؤال يعني عن عن عن فرق
الانقاذ والبحث والتقصي ايضا في هاتاي هل
هي يعني
بذات الامل
بذات العمل ايضا حتى السرعه محاوله ايضا
ايجاد ناجيج مثل ما يعني الصوره التي
نقلناها اليوم مع الزميل غسان ابو اللوز
من منطقه
منطقه مركز الزلزال ايضا في تركيا
كهرباء مرعش كهرمان مرعش نعم هنالك انت
تسال ربما عن الماء نعم انت تسال عن
المعنويات اذا ما كانت في ذات القوه في
الايام الماضيه انا ما اشاهده انهم يعملون
بذات القوه وبذات الحماس وينتشرون في كل
مكان وهنالك يعني فرق تجوب الشوارع
والطرقات للوصول الى احياء ولكن في بصراحه
وبوضوح اعداد فرق الانقاذ قليله جدا لانه
هنالك احياء انا كنت تحدثت الى شاب سوري
اليوم لديه 30 من اسر من اقاربه في بنايه
واحده انهارت ولم يصلها رجال الانقاذ بعد
لان هنالك ضغط كبير وحينما يسال يقول له
ونحن اذا كان هنالك اصوات ابلغنا ان لم
يكن هنالك اصوات في الاولويه للبنايات
التي يتواجد فيها احياء وفيها اصوات نعم
نايف اسمعك اعمارنا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
هذه الصوره التي نقلتها لنا من هطاي في
الجنوب التركي سنعود اليك حاله ما جده
جديد ايضا او يعني
اصبحت لدينا صوره اخرى من منطقه اخرى شكرا
جزيلا لك مراسل موفد العربي عمار الهندي
من هاتاي اذا نتابع وياكم هذه الاخبار
العاجله اسفل الشاشه بدء دخول شاحنات
المساعدات السعوديه من تركيا الى سوريا
عبر معبر باب الهوى اذا بدء دخول شاحنات
عبر باب عبر معبر باب الهوى ومعنى من معبر
باب الحمام وفد العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن مرحبا بك معي انت من يعني امام
احد المعابر التي يعني تدخل منها
المساعدات اللغاتيه والانسانيه ايضا كذلك
كيف هي الصوره وفيما يخص ايضا المساعدات
السعوديه كيف تسير العمليه انكتب بالقرب
منها
بالفعل اتواجد بالقرب من منفذ باب الهوى
وهو منفذ محادي لباب الحمام الذي ستدخل
منها هذه المساعدات وبالفعل دخلت ما يقارب
احد عشر شاحنه حاليا تدخل وتعبر من المنفذ
التركي غصن الزيتون الى المنفذ السوري باب
الحمام
لتعبر مباشره الى مختلف المناطق السوريه
التي سيتم فيها توزيع المساعدات وهنا
نتحدث عن عدد من المناطق تحديدا في الشمال
الغربي بسوريا في ادلب وفي المناطق
المتضرره وهي عددها 22 منطقه عدد ضخم من
هذه المساعدات تتحدث عن 104 اطنان مباشره
وهي محمله على طائره كامله تم تخصيصها
للشمال الغربي من سوريا وسيتم توزيعها
مباشره بعد دخولها الى
المتضررين عبر متعهد من سوريا وهو احد
الذين تواجدت معهم قبل قليل وسالته حول
كيفيه ضمان وصول هذه المساعدات قال بانهم
سيوصلونها مباشره الى الاماكن الاكثر
تضررا والناس الذين يحتاجون هذه المساعدات
نوعيه هذه المساعدات قال بانها مساعدات
ايوائيه ومساعدات غذائيه ومساعدات طبيه
ودوائيه والمساعدات التي يحتاجها السوريون
كما قال لي بان المساعدات السعوديه هي اول
مساعدات دوليه تدخل الى سوريا منذ ان وقع
الزلزال قبل سته ايام اذا هذه المساعدات
كما تحدث هي المساعدات السعوديه
والدوليه الاولى التي تدخل الى سوريا عبر
منطقه باب الحمام وبعد اقل من ساعاتي الان
كنا نود ان نكون معكم بصوت وصوره ولكن
بسبب سوء سمكه الاتصال انا اشاهد الان
الشاحنات تعبر من المنفذ التركي باب الغصن
او غصن الزيتون الى منفذ باب الحمام وهي
المنطقه السوريه تنعبر معها الى الجانب
السوري
لنطلع على على هذه المساعدات وايضا كيفيه
ايصالها
والمستفيدين منها بالاضافه الى ذلك هذه
المساعدات لن تكون الاخيره بحسب تصريحات
مسؤوليه مركز الملك سلمان ومسؤوليه
المساعدات السعوديه بشكل عام التي تم
تصييرها بشكل عاجل الى سوريا وتركيا على
حد سواء هذه المساعدات التي تدخل الى
سوريا هي الاولى من نوعها على المستوى
التواليخ وايضا ستكون بحجم ضخم كما اشاهد
احد عشر شاحنه محمله بكافه المساعدات
الغذائيه والدوائيه والايوائيه وايضا
الملابس الشتويه
والادوات التي يتم الاستفاده منها للدفع
بهذا الجو البارد جدا للمساعده المتضررين
السوريين على مواجهه
الاضرار التي نجمت جراء هذا الزلزال نايف
عبد المحسن ماذا عن عمليه الاستلام
والتسليم مدى ايضا كذلك عن عمليه النقل
عبر هذا المعبر هل كانت سلسه في الاجراءات
اما اخذت وقت طويل وربما ايضا حتى ساعات
حتى يتم ادخالها الى الشمال الغربي السوري
انت من خلال رصدك ووجودك في امام هذه
المعابر باب الحمام او ايضا كذلك معبر باب
الهواء
نعم نايف في الحقيقه كان هنالك عدد من
الخيارات المطروحه امام كل المسؤولين عن
هذه المساعدات السعوديه التي يتم ادخالها
المنفذ الموجود في انطاكيا ام المنفذين
الموجدين هنا في غازي عنتاب وهنا نتحدث عن
المنافذ التي تعمل ولكن تم اختيار منفذ
باب الحمام وهو محادي لباب الهواء وكلا
المنفذين يؤديان الى منطقه متضرره بشكل
كامل وهي الاشد حاجه ان هذه المساعدات
ستدخل مباشره وربما تكون خلال اقل من ساعه
بيد
متضررين لقرب هذه هذه القرى القريبه وهنا
نتحدث عن القرى المحاديه للحدود التركيه
من جهه من جهه غازيه عنتاب ايضا تم اختيار
هذا المنفذ نظرا لسهوله الاجراءات شاهدت
هنالك ايضا في في هذه اللحظات يتواجد عدد
من المسؤولين الاتراك
والسعوديين جنبا الى جنبه نتحدث عن منظمه
افاده التي هي مسؤوله عن عمليات توزيع
المساعدات وعن عمليات ايضا تسهيل دخول
المساعدات عبر
المساعدات الدوليه وتم التنسيق لكي يمر
هذا هذه المساعدات نظرا
للاوضاع الامنيه في سوريا واختلاف مناطق
السيطره نتحدث عن كل منطقه يسيطر عليها
طرف معين وفصيل معين والسعوديه قالت
بتصريحات سابقه لعبد الله الربيع المشرف
العام على الدكتور عبدالله ربيع المشرف
العام على سلمان انها اخر مساعدات الجميع
بغض النظر عن
اين يكون في هذه اي ارض يكون تحديدا سيطره
من تكون على هذه الارض فبالتالي
يبدو اننا فقدنا الصوت الزميل عبد المحسن
الحربي وهو كما اوضح قبل قليل بان شبكه
الاتصالات وايضا الانترنت تكاد تكون
معدومه في هذه المنطقه الحدوديه بين تركيا
وسوريا تحديدا في معبر باب الحمام شكرا
جزيلا لهم وفدل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
قالت مديره اداره البرامج بالمكتبه
الاقليمي لشرق المتوسط التابع لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه رنا الحجه ان نحو 200 الف
سوري بمحافظه حلب باتوا بلا ماوى جراء
الدمار الذي الحقه الزلزال بمباني المدينه
وحتى في مؤتمر صحفي المجتمع الدولي على
تقديم المزيد من المساعدات لاغاثه ضحايا
الزلزال
اشدد على ان المجتمع الدولي قدم الكثير من
الالتزامات وعبر عن اراده كبيره في حشد
المساعده هناك الكثير من الجهود المبذوله
لتقديم المساعدات للمتضررين لكن لا تزال
هناك حاجه ماسه لزياده المساعدات لان حجم
الدمار هائل
من جانبه قال مدير الطوارئ الاقليميه بشرق
المتوسط التابع لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
ريتشارد بيرنان ان منظمه الصحه تحشد
المجتمع الدولي لجمع اكثر من اربعين مليون
دولار لزياده دعم المتضررين من الزلزال
الذي ضرب سوريا
هناك طائره ستصل في غضون ساعات محمله
بثلاثه واربعين طنا من المساعدات نحن لا
نقوم بمازل عن بقيه شركائنا في الحكومه
التقينا في الايام الماضيه ثلاث مرات
مسؤولي وزاره الصحه حتى نقف على
احتياجاتهم بشكل دقيق نعمل بشكل وثيق مع
شركائنا في الامم المتحده والمنظمات غير
الحكوميه للحصول على المزيد من المساعدات
اعتقد انه مع مرور كل ساعه ومع مرور كل
يوم يتحسن العمل الاغاثي بشكل اكبر منظمه
الصحه العالميه توجه نداء لجمع اكثر من 40
مليون دولار وبذلك سنتمكن من زياده
المساعدات التي يحتاجها ضحايا الزلزال في
شمال سوريا نحن بحاجه للتمويل وزياده
المساعدات ودعم زملائنا السوريين حتى يقدم
المساعدات للمحتاجين خصوصا في ظل ترد
القطاع الصحي سوريا
ومعنا من ريفيه ادلب سرمدا متطوعه بالدفاع
المدني السوريين لدى الراشد سيدنا مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه الحيه والمباشره
على شاشه العربيه هل انتهيتم فعلا من كل
المحاولات او عمليات
انقاذ اي ناجين وبداتم فعليا بانتشال فقط
الجثث وربما ردم المباني المتهالكه او حتى
التي لم تسوى بالارض حتى الان
مرحبا بك بدا عمل الدفاع المدني منذ ساعات
حدود الزلزال منذ سته ايام حاليا اكثر من
100 ساعه على عمل من قبل المتطوعي الدفاع
المدني
الدفاع المدني يعمل في اليه البحث
وانتشار الضحايا ولكن لا نفقد الامل في
وجود احياء تحت الارض تحت الركام
الساعات الذهبيه
72 ساعه
نفذوا ولكن يوجد لدينا امل في وجود احياء
تحت
الركام يعمل الدفاع المدني بشكل مستمر في
كذا مناطق في مناطق انتهى من العمل
فيها ولكن لا يزال يعمل في عمليه البحث في
منطقه جنديرس في منطقه حارم بسنيه سلقين
لا توجد احياء منذ خروج ناجين احياء من
تحت الركام منذ البارحه وصل عدد الوفيات
تقريبا الى
2160 حاله وفاه كذلك عدد الاصابات هو ثابت
منذ البارحه 2950 ولكن عدد الوفيات بسبب
وجود خروج او انتشال
وفيات من تحت الانقاذ فهو في بشكل
متزايد
فرق الدفاع المدني مستمره ولكن لديها
الامل ولكن بخروج الاحياء ولكن هذا الامر
ضعيف جدا
الا في حال حدثت
معجزه
وخاصه انه الطقس كثير بارد في حال كان
هناك نزيف فان فان المصابين تحت الركام في
حال كان لديهم نزيف والبروده الشديده تؤدي
الى انخفاض
حراره الجسم ويؤدي الى الدخول في صدمه
وكذلك اذا كان هناك حالات متلازمه الهرس
واستمرت لايام وهي لديها متلازمه هرس هذا
يؤدي الى تسمم فسفوري داخل الجسم الامل
موجود ولكن
اللي راح ينجي هو
باعجوبه معجزه طيب هل وصلتكم اي مساعدات
من فرق انقاذ او مسعفين او متطوعين ايضا
حتى الدوليين في الشمال السوري
بالنسبه للمساعدات الانقاذ منذ ساعات
الاولى من حدوث الزلزال ناشد الدفاع
المدني جميع دول الدول والامم المتحده في
في مسانده الدفاع المدني باليات ثقيله
بمعدات بحث وانقاذ بفرق انقاذ متخصصه
دوليه ولكن للاسف لم يصل اي شيء للدفاع
المدني ولم يساند الدفاع المدني سوى فريق
تطوعي مصري وكذلك اسباني ولكن لا يمتلكون
اي معدات يستعملون معدات الدفاع المدني
كانت الجهود اللي موجوده كانت جهود اللي
كانت عم تساعد الدفاع المدني هي جهود
محليه تكاتف الاهالي المدنيين في شمال غرب
سوريا كذلك ساعدوا المدنيين في مسانده
الدفاع المدني باليات ثقيله في شمال غرب
سوريا ولكن لم تصل اي معدات اي مساعدات اي
معدات انقاذ
اليات انقاذ ولا حتى
من المجتمع الدولي للدفاع المدني طيب اريد
السؤال ايضا كذلك
وعود من قبل الدول الشركاء للدفاع المدني
ونحن متوقعون وصول مساعدات من قبل المانيا
من قبل الدنمارك من قبل بريطانيا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فرنسا هذه الدول سيده
ندى
نعم ما الذي وعدتكم بهذه الدول ما هي
نوعيه المساعدات التي ستقدمها لكم بوصول
لا نعرف لحد الان ما هي اليه ما هي
المساعدات ولكن هناك وعود ومتوقعين وصولها
في الساعات المقبله ولكن
لم تصل اي مساعدات من قبل الامم المتحده
وصلت مساعدات هي مساعدات من المنظمات من
من السعوديه
وصلت ولكن هاي كلها من كردستان العراق
ولكن كل هذه المساعدات كانت انسانيه لم
يكن اي هناك مساعدات
لوجستيه للدفاع المدني
وكذلك المنظمات المحليه اللي موجوده في
شمال غرب سوريا ولكن لا لا تكفي هذه
المساعدات لا تكفي
المدنيين الناجين من الكارثه وخاصه
وعن ايضا حتى ربما الذين تضرروا من هذه
الزلازل اذا سمحت لي سيده ندى هذه صور
مباشره نتابعها واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام
على شاشه العربيه
ربما عمليه انقاذ احد
من يعني بقوا تحت الركام وتحت المباني
المهدمه والمباني ايضا التي
انهارت بسبب الزلزال المدمر في تركيا في
مدينه البستان تحديدا فرق الانقاذ
والطوارئ وكذلك ايضا المسعفين فرق ربما
ايضا تركيا ودوليه ايضا تتابع حاله
يعني من تم اخراجه من تحت الانقاض في هذه
الصوره يعني لا نعلم ان كان حيا ام قضى
تحت الانقاض نحن نتحدث اليوم عن سته ايام
بعد هذه الفاجعه
المدمره هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا هذه الصور ننقلها لكم من مدينه
البستان في تركيا هناك تجمع اذا والتفاف
يعني احد من تم اخراجهم من تحت انقاب
الركام عمليه انقاذ ربما انها نجحت يعني
في ان يتم اخراج هذا الشخص
حيا وبصحه وعافيه سنتابع كلنا تابعنا
واياكم اليوم عائشه التي خرجت نعم الان
نتابع هذه الصور لاخراج الدفاع المدني
بفرق الانقاذ ايضا لاحد من كانوا عالقين
تحت الركام وتحت احد المباني
المنهاره في مدينه البستان يبدو فعلا ان
فرق الالقاد قد اخرجت يعني هذا الشخص الذي
كان تحت الركام وايضا بقى لمده اكثر من
125 ساعه تحت الانقاض والركام يعني نتمنى
انه خرج بصحه وعافيه بانه ايضا لم يقضي
تحت هذه الامطار ويبدو انه بصحه وعافيه
ايضا هذه لحظات يعني مباشره تنقلها لكم
العربيه ليست الاولى واكثر من لقطات يعني
اكثر من لقطه ربما اكثر من حدث واكثر من
قصه تابعنا واياكم على شاشه العربيه منذ
صباح اليوم لاخراج العالقين من تحت
الانقاض في عده مدن واخرها الان مدينه
البستان التركيه تحول مباشره الى غازي
عنتاب من هناك العقيد محمد الحمادي
المتحدث الرسمي للدفاع المدني سيد محمد
مرحبا بك معي اولا اريد ان اسال عن
المساعدات الاغاثيه المساعدات ايضا
الانسانيه ما تحتاجونه او ما يعني تحتاجه
هذه المناطق من فرق بحث من فرق انقاذ ايضا
كذلك في الداخل التركي ما الذي قدمتموه
حتى هذه اللحظه سيد محمد
مساء الخير لك وللجميع فريق البحث انقاذ
السعودي من ضمن
المساعدات المتنوعه التي يوجه بها مولاي
خادم الحرمين ولي العهد حيث تنوعت
المساعدات الى مواد غذائيه وطبيبيه اضافه
الى تحرك الوصول فريق البحث للقائد
السعودي وهو فريق دولي في مجال اعمال
البحث والانقاذ ويضم تخصصات متنوعه وطبيه
وهندسيه بالاضافه الى تجهيزات الفنيه
اللازمه لاعمال البحث والانقاذ وصل يوم
امس علامات طائرتين اليوم موجودين في
منطقه الابراهيملي في احد الابنيه
المنهاره حيث باشر فريق البحث والانقاذ
السعودي اعماله في البحث
منذ صباح اليوم ولا زالت اعمال البحث
مستمره
موقع اخر ممكن ان يبدا فرقه البحث انقاذ
السعودي ايضا التعامل معه هو قريب من
الموقع الاول جه كبيره ومستمره الحقيقه
يقوم بها فريق البحث القاضي السعودي من
ضمن منظومه عمل المرك مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه
والمساعده بالاضافه الى ايضا طواقم من
الهلال الاحمر والمتطوعين الحقيقه الكل
يعمل في منظومه
انسانيه واحده كم عدد يعني افراد هذا
الفريق الذي وصل الى هذه المناطق عقيد
محمد
فريق البحث القادم السعودي يتجاوز المئه
فرد بين ضابط وفرد وتخصصات طبيه وهندسيه
وايضا فنيين متخصصين في الاعمال الدقيقه
بالاضافه الى اليات ومعدات وتجهيزات دوليه
في مجال البحث والانقاذ اين سيتركز عمل
يعني هؤلاء
يعني هذا الفريق اولا وكذلك المتطوعين
الذين وصلوا معهم بالتاكيد هناك تنسيق مع
منظمه دولي بحثا قائد رائد التي يتم توزيع
المواقع بين الفرق الانقراض التي تباشر
لكي يتم توزيع الجهود حاليا موجودين في
منطقه
الابراهيملي في ابراج البولان
للعمل فيها منذ صباح اليوم ايضا هناك برج
مجاور ايضا سيتم مباشره من قبل فريق
الانقاذ بالتنسيق مع منظمه سراج الدوليه
للبحث والانقاذ ممتاز يعني نحن عقيد محمد
منذ اليوم يعني في كافه المناطق التي
نغطيها او ايضا نشاهد فيها محاولات انقاذ
ومحاولات بحث ايضا ربما يعني السؤال دائما
الذي نساله عن يعني
المساعدات في المعدات التي
تساعد فرق البحث والانقاذ بالنسبه للفريق
السعودي ما هي المساعدات ايضا التي
سيقدمها من هذا الجانب من ناحيه المعدات
التي ستقدم ستساهم ايضا ربما في الرفع
ينتقل الى المناطق المتضرره والمنكوبه
بكامل تجهيزاته
والتي تساعد
لاتمام وتنفيذ مهام المسؤوليه تفائل
المعدات والتجهيزات الموجوده يتم
استخدامها في اعمال البحث يتم الاستعانه
فيها في اعمال
الرصد
فرق الكي 9 او الوسائل الحيه التي تستشعر
الاشخاص المحتجزين تحت الانقاذ جميع هذه
الوسائل والتقنيات والفرق هي ضمن الادوات
التي يتم استخدامها قبل فريق البحث عن
قائد السعودي والموجود الان في تركيا
وتحديدا في عنتاب كم سيستمر عملهم في هذه
المناطق عقيد محمد هل هناك مده محدده
منسقه مع الجانب التركي
ومستمرين في الاعمال الموقع الموجودين
الان سيستمر العمل فيه حتى يتم الانتهاء
والتاكد من عدم وجود حالات او الانتهاء
تماما من تمشيط الموقع ومن ثم مواقع اخرى
وفق التنسيق محمد شكرا جزيلا لك على وجودك
معي في هذه التغطيه من غازي عنتاب العقيد
محمد المحمدي المتحدث الرسمي للدفاع
المدني السعودي
ونبقى في غازي عنتاب ينضم الينا من هناك
زيدان زنكلو مراسل العربيه زيدان مرحبا بك
معي في هذه
التغطيه المباشره زيدان الصوره في غازي
عنتاب يبدو الان انها تتحول الى صوره
مكتمله الاركان بالمساعدات الاغاثيه
والانسانيه ايضا كذلك
وغيرها لكن الجانب الاخر ايضا فيما يخص
عمليات البحث عمليات الانقاذ المساعده
محاوله يعني انتشال ربما الناجين من تحت
الانقاض كيف
تسير هذه بتلك موازاتهم مع بعضهم البعض
نعم لا شك ان اننا في اليوم السادس منذ
وقوع هذه الكارثه وكما تشاهد
اصلاحيه في ولايه غازي عنتاب هذه المدينه
تقريبا نصف المباني التي فيها دمرت وعشرات
المباني
عشرات المباني الاخرى باتت تقريبا للسقوط
وغير صالحه للسكن نكبه كبيره في هذه
المدينه
يعني حقيقه اثار الدمار واسعه لا يمكن
وصلها هذه هذا المشهد الذي نصوره الان هو
حي بالكامل سقط انهار بالكامل بقي على
الارض لم يبقى سوى هذا البناء واقفا لكنه
ايضا غير صالح للسكن ستقوم السلطات
التركيه بهدمه بعد انتهاء عمليات البحث
حتى الان عمليات البحث ما تزال مستمره كما
تشاهدون نحن قريبين جدا من فرق الانقاذ
التي تحاول العثور على اشخاص ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض في هذا المبنى
التقديرات تتراوح انهم خمسه اشخاص لكن انا
حتى اكون دقيق اكثر ساحاول ان اسال احد
ذوي الاشخاص العالقين هذا المبنى ساسال
السيد اردال وله وصهره ايضا كان تحت
الانقاض لكن اعذروني الضوضاء في المحيط
تمنعنا من سماع اي شيء ساحاول ان اتكلم
واجري المقابله معه باللغه التركيه ومن ثم
اترجمها لكم او الاقصى ما قاله مباشره عبر
الهواء
مرحبا
دير
خارقا
بيرناول يعني
انه
يعني عجب بها
ان شاء الله شكرا
يعني انا لم استطع ان اسمع كل ما تحدث به
قريب احد الاشخاص الذي كان عالقا هنا لكن
ساحاول ان الخص تقريبا ما سمعته كان يتحدث
عن وجود خمسه اشخاص في هذا المبنى على ما
اذكر ثلاثه رجال وسيدتان حسب ما سمعت منه
ان سيده وابنها كانوا مدفونين او ما زالوا
تحت الانقاظ هنا حيث ارجو من زميلي المصور
ان يوجه الكاميرا الى هناك حسب ما فهمته
ان سيد وابنها هم ما زالوا مدفونين تحت
الانقاض حيث تحاول فرق الانقاذ فرق
الانقاذ هناك الوصول اليهم اخبرني انهم
يوم امس احضروا كاميرات حراريه لمراقبه
هذا المكان وبحسب ما فهمت ما فهمت طبعا لم
اسمع كل ما يتحدث به بسبب الالات العملاقه
الالات الحفر العملاقه التي
قال لك نعم نعم التي تعمل بجانبنا لكن حسب
ما فهمت من كلامه انهم احضروا كاميرات
مراقبه حراريه الى هذا المكان يوم امس
وقاموا بالكشف عن هذا الموقع على ما اعتقد
انه لم يجدوا شيء حسب ما سمعت لا حتى لا
اكون اكون امينا لم اسمع الاجابه بشكل
كامل لكنهم احضروا كاميرات المراقبه
ويحاولون الان استكمال العمل للوصول الى
اشخاص ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ ربما يعني هو
لم ينفي ان يكون هناك احد على قيد الحياه
قال انه يامل ان يكون هناك اشخاص على قيد
الحياه لكن الاعمال تستمر بالمحصله ما زال
تحت هذا الركام خمسه اشخاص من ضمن هذا
الحي الكبير الذي نشاهده الان قد دمر
بالكامل هذه النقطه الوحيده التي بقيت
التي بقي فرق او المتطوعون وعناصر فرق
الانقاذ ايضا هناك عناصر من الجيش التركي
معهم يساعدونهم في عم رفع الانقاض والبحث
هذه النقطه الوحيده في هذا الحي الكامل حي
كامل هذا البناء مكون من خمس طوابق وهناك
عده مباني مجاوره وايضا مباني في الخلف كل
هذا الحي انهار بالكامل فقط هذه النقطه
التي تعمل بها الان فرق الانقاذ باقي
النقاط قد تم تنشيطها بالكامل والبحث
بالكامل وجاري ازاله الانقاض من هنالك
وفقط هذه النقطه التي امامنا هي التي ما
زال او ما زالت فرق الانقاذ تعمل بها
اتمنى ان شاء الله لهم السلامه والنجاه
ايضا من بقوا تحت هذه الانقاض شكرا جزيلا
لك من غازي عنتاب زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه
ونشاهد واياكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور لفريق
البحث والانقاذ السعودي وهو يواصل عملياته
في المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال وكان قبل
قليل متحدث الدفاع المدني السعودي قد ذكر
بان فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي قد وصل
الى المناطق المنكوبه جنوبي تركيا وعدد
هذا الفريق يصل لاكثر من مئات شخص
اعود واياكم مره اخرى الى ريف ادلب سرمدا
والى ضيفته المتطوعه بالدفاع المدني
السوري نداء الراشد مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى
يعني نحن انتقلنا بكاميرا العربيه لاكثر
من منطقه اعمال
الاغاثه اعمال محاوله طبعا الحصول يعني
على
بارقه امل في اكثر من مكان لم تنطفئ حتى
هذه اللحظه لكن ما يلزم في مثل هذه بمثل
هذه اللحظات هي وجود ربما معدات وايضا
كذلك مؤن
للمسعفين للمنقذين لفريق البحث والانقاذ
المتواجد في هذه المناطق بالنسبه لكم انتم
في الشمال السوري ما الذي تحتاجونه خلال
الايام القادمه تطلبونه ايضا حتى من الدول
او ربما من المنظمات الاغاثيه والانسانيه
التي تقدم المساعدات اليكم او على الاقل
التي وعدتكم بمساعدات خلال ساعات القليله
القادمه
مرحبا بك هلا نحن بحاجه الى معدات مثل ما
قلت لك في حال معدات ثقيله بحاجه الى
معدات بحث وانقاذ بحاجه الى كيول كدفاع
بحاجه الى مستهلكات طبيه بحاجه الى هدول
لانه نحن نمكن الدفاع المدني في حال صار
اي كارثه او اي لا سمح الله او اي شيء
طارئ فيكون الدفاع المدني مستعد
بامكانياته وتكون امكانياته كتير قويه
كمان محتاج للايات الثقليه الثقيله لرفع
الانقاذ وترحيلها في الساعات في بعد
انتهاء عمليه البحث
والانقاذ
وكذلك بحاجه
لاصلاح الطرقات رفع رفع الطرق رفع الطرقام
عن الطرقات وفتحها كذلك بحاجه الى ترميم
ربنا التحتيه بحاجه الى فيول
لاستمرار عمليه الاسعاف في شمال غرب سوريا
كذلك
الى مستهلكات طبيه القطاع الطبي قبل قبل
هاي الكارثه كان منهك وحاليا اجت الكارثه
زاد عليه اضعاف بحاجه بحاجه كذلك الى
معدات طبيه مستهلكات طبيه اسعافيه وكذلك
علاجيه لمتابعه حاله الضحايا الناجين من
الكارثه كذلك الناس بحاجه الى جميع مقومات
الحياه الناس اللي نجت من الكارثه موجوده
حاليا في مراكز الايواء كذلك
المدنيين التي ابنيتهم متصدعه فهم يفترشون
الاراضي يفترشون البساتين يفترشون مراكز
الايواء بحاجه الى بحاجه الى خيم بحاجه
الى مياه غذاء تدفئه الى جميع مقاومات
اللبس الى جميع مقومات الحياه
الاساسيه هناك حاجات كبيره في شمال غرب
سوريا شمال غرب سوريا قبل سته
اشباط غير بعد سته اشباط صارت الحاجه اكبر
صارت
الناس بحاجه حتى تحتاج الى خيمه يعني حتى
اهالي المخيمات في شمال غرب سوريا صارت
تستدعي الناجين والابيتون الابنيه
المتصدعه الى المكوث مع اهالي المخيمات
هذه هي الحاجات حاجاتنا الى المعدات سواء
كانت الثقيله الى المعدات البحث والانقاذ
الى الفيول الى المستهلكات الطبيه الى
جميع مقومات الحياه يلي تساعد على
حياه المدنيين
طيب اشكرك جزيل الشكر من ريفي ادلب سرمدا
المتطوعه بالدفاع المدني السوري ندى
الراشد
سنواصل معكم تغطيتنا للزلزال لكن نتوقف مع
بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى حيث اعلن
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
عن استعداد بلاده للتفاوض مع كيا دون شروط
مسبقه مشددا على مراعاه المفاوضات للاهداف
الروسيه المسبق الاعلان عنها وقال ايضا ان
قرار المفاوضات مع موسكو لا يتخذ في كييف
بل في واشنطن او بروكسل ماء متهما الجانب
الاوكراني بقطع المفاوضات رغم بدء روسيا
بها فعليا
قال السفير الروسي في واشنطن اناتولي
انوتوف انه في حال قررت واشنطن استئناف
انشطه قوات العمليات الخاصه في اوكرانيا
فسيكون ذلك بمثابه مشاركه مفتوحه لقواتها
النظاميه بالصراع كما اكد السفير الروسي
ان الولايات المتحده تتغاضى عن الفضاء
التي ترتكبها مثل اعدامات اسرى الحرب
الروسيين والقصف اليومي على دون باس
وزابولوجيا وخيرسون حذرا بان تورط
الولايات المتحده في مواجهه مع روسيا يقود
العالم الى عواقب لا يمكن التنبؤ بها
اعلن رئيس مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
ضروره ان تسيطر القوات الروسيه على مدينه
بخموت الاستراتيجيه للمضي قدما في حملتها
لافتا الى ان القوات الروسيه تواجه مقاومه
شرسه من قبل الجيش الاوكراني واضاف في
مقابله وصفت بالنادره اجراها معه مراسل
عسكري روسي ان على روسي ان تضع اهدافا
واضحه تعتمد
على ترسيخ وجودها بقوه شرق اوكرانيا او
المضي قدما للسيطره على المزيد من الاراضي
قال المستشار برئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل
لابو حديث روسيا عن عدم مغادره اراضي
اوكرانيا ضمن التصريحات دوريه تدلي بها عن
السلام والمحادثات دليل اخر على ان
المحادثات بين الجانبين المستبعده تماما
مضيفا بان بان اما ان تنتصر اوكرانيا او
تظل الحرب في اوروبا بلا نهايه وتهيمن
روسيا بشكل اجرامي على العالم على حد وصفه
افادت صحيفه المانيه عن زياده في اعمال
التجسس التي يقوم بها عملاء للمخابرات
الايرانيه على المعرضين الايرانيين الذين
يعيشون في يعيشون في المانيا في الفتره
الماضيه واشارت الى ان عمليات التجسس زادت
بشكل كبير بعد بدء الاحتجاجات في ايران
ووفقا للصحيفه فقد قالت الحكومه الالمانيه
ان الحكام في ايران يعتبرون ان جماعات
المعارضه الايرانيه تهدد استمرار النظام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كشف رئيس جهاز المخابرات الداخليه
الالمانيه ان الصين تمارس انشطه التجسس
سياسي ضد برلين واكد ان بكين تطور انشطه
تجسس ونفوذ واسعه النطاق كما حذر من ان
الاعتماد الاقتصادي على الصين يمكن
استغلاله ايضا في النفوذ السياسي
قال المتحدث باسم البنتاجون ان طائره
مقاتله من طراز اف 22 اسقطت هدفا كان يحلق
فوق اجواء الاسكا مشيرا الى ان الهدف كان
يحلق على ارتفاع 40 الف قدم ما يمثل
تهديدا للطائرات المدنيه
من رئيس الولايات المتحده اسقطت مقاتله
امريكيه من طراز اف 22 تابعه للقياده
الشماليه هدفا يحلق على علو مرتفع فوق
ساحل الاسكا الشمالي اسقطت الهدف فوق
المياه الاقليميه القياده الشماليه للقوات
الجويه الامريكيه كانت قد رصدت الهدف في
التاسع من فبراير الجاري محلقا على ارتفاع
اربعين الف قدم وحددت هويته باستخدام
طائره مقاتله وهو ما يشكل تهديدا للطائرات
المدنيه
دع الفرنسيه الى تعبئه جديده ضد اصلاح
نظام التقاعد والذي لا يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره
بين اوساط الشعب الفرنسي وتامل النقابات
الفرنسيه في مشاركه كبيره في التظاهرات
التي تنظم يوم السبت اي في عطله نهايه
الاسبوع ليتاع ليتاح للعاملين غير
القادرين على الاضراب المشاركه في
التظاهرات كما ذكرت بعض المصادر انه من
المتوقع ان يشارك في التعبئه من بين 600
الف الى 800 الف شخص في مختلف مناطق
البلاد
تستعد جزيره نور فولك الاستراليه لمواجهه
رياحي قويه ضمن تاثيرات اعصار غابريل
المتوجه نحو نيوزيلندا بسرعه تبلغ 155 كم
في الساعه وفق مكتب الارصاد الجويه في
استراليا واصدرت هيئه اداره الطوارئ في
جزيره نور فولك اندارا حتت فيه الناس على
البقاء في المنازل
والبقاء في مقرات العمل
وليس من الشركات
بعد هذه الجوله السريعه معكم على الاخبار
العالميه التغطيه معكم مستمره نستمر فيها
لكارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
[موسيقى]
تغطيه العربيه من استوديوهاتها في الرياض
انتهت بهذه الساعه الاخباريه التي تابعنا
معكم فيها اثار الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا انتقل الان بالكلمه وتغطيه
المباشره الى الزميل طالب كنعان من
استديوهاتنا في دبي اليك طالب